DRAKE IS HERE.
AND ON THE MIC.
>> SO GOOD TO BE HOME, BOYS.
GET ME ON THE LINE, JACK, YOU
KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
IT'S BEEN A SOLID TWO YEARS OF
DRINKING THESE AT HOME.
[ Laughter ]
HAPPY TO BE BACK.
>> Matt: OH, IT WAS FEBRUARY
OF 2020, THEN WE WENT TO BUBBLE,
THEN IT WAS TAMPA.
AND HERE WE ARE.
FEELS GOOD, DOESN'T IT, THOUGH?
>> IT FEELS GOOD TO SEE YOU GUYS
BACK.
I SWEAR YOU GUYS ARE REVERSE
AGING.
IT'S LIKE A.
BENJAMIN BUTTONTHING GOING ON.
SUITS LOOK EMacLASS.
>> Matt: WE'RE TRYING TO --
IMMACULATE.
>> Matt: WE'RE TRYING TO GET
IT ALL STRAIGHT.
>> SO GREAT TO BE AROUND PEOPLE
AGAIN.
SEE ALL THESE FACES, YOU KNOW.
>> Matt: IT REALLY IS.
>> I'M FEELING IN HIGH SPIRITS,
BOYS.
[ Laughter ]
>> Jack: HAPPY TO HAVE YOU.
>> IN HIGH SPIRITS.
I GOT MY BROTHER SHOWTIME WITH
ME TODAY.
>> Matt: WE SEE THAT.
SHOWTIME.
>> DEFINITELY AN AISRAEL MAAING
BALLER FROM THE CITY SPREADING A
POT OF POSITIVITY TO THE KIDS --
AN AMAZING BALLER.
SHOWING A LOT OF LOVE.
LOOK AT THIS YOUNG TEAM.
ATHLETIC.
>> Matt: YEAH.
BARNES AND BANTON OUT AT THE
HOUSE?
>> OF COURSE.
THAT'S MY GUYS.
"B" BOY.
REALLY TRENCH, BABY.
>> Matt: HOW DID IT LOOK?
DID YOU RUN OUT THERE?
>> NO.
IT WAS REALLY EARLY IN THE
MORNING, I THINK, FROM WHAT I
REMEMBER.
[ Laughter ]
I WAS DELIRIOUS.
I WAS FINISHING THE ALBUM.
I DON'T REMEMBER ANYTHING.
I WOKE UP IN THE POOL THAT DAY
FROM WHAT I REMEMBER.
[ Laughter ]
>> Matt: JACK'S DONE THAT
BEFORE.
[ Laughter ]
>> Jack: OH, YEAH.
YOU KNOW WHAT, IT DOES NOT MAKE
ME A BAD GUY.
>> NOT AT ALL.
OF COURSAL.
[ Laughter ]
OF COURSE.
TALK TO ME.
HOW YOU GUYS BEEN?
HOW'S EVERYTHING?
>> Matt: GOOD.
YOU WALK BACK, THE ENERGY, THE
PEOPLE AS YOU SAID, IT'S JUST
GOOD TO BE BACKCOURTSIDE.
>> IT CERTAINLY IS.
SEEING FANS IN THE STANDS.
>> Jack: THE LAST TIME I SAW
YOU YOU GAVE ME A FREDERICO HAT.
>> Matt: THAT WAS A LONG TIME
AGO.
>> THE BIRTH OF A LEGEND.
STUCK WITH US, TOO.
GOD BLESS HIS HEART.
>> Jack: I STILL HAVE THE HAT.
>> HE LOVED IT.
WE HAVE TO BRING IT BACK OUT.
[ Laughter ]
>> Matt: HE RODE THAT
FREDERICO FOR A WHILE.
>> STILL IS.
LOOK AT HIM.
[ Laughter ]
>> STILL RIDING THAT WAVE FOR
SURE.
[ Laughter ]
>> Jack: HOW ABOUT THE TIMING?
>> I APPRECIATE YOU GUYS HAVING
ME BACK ON THE AIR, THOUGH.
>> Matt: ANY TIME, YOU KNOW
THAT.
>> Jack: HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO
YOUR SON.
FOURTH BIRTHDAY TODAY.
>> SON TURNED FOUR TODAY.
>> Matt: HAD THE PARTY
YESTERDAY?
>> I'M TURNING 24 ON THE 24th.
MY CHAMPAGNIE BIRTHDAY.
[ Laughter ]
NA, I'M GETTING OLD THIS YEAR.
I'M GETTING OLD THIS YEAR.
>> Matt: NOT TRUE.
NOT TRUE.
>> I MEAN, YOU KNOW, IT IS WHAT
IT IS.
>> Matt: IT HAPPENS.
>> WE'VE BEEN HOLDING IT DOWN
FOR THE CITY FOR A LONG TIME.
BY THE WAY, I KNOW THE CITY IS
WATCHING TONIGHT.
I WANT TO SEND MY LOVE TO
EVERYBODY, YOU KNOW.
IT WAS A TOUGH FIGHT.
IT WAS A TOUGH FIGHT FOR THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS, AND I WANT TO
SEND MY REGARDS AND MY LOVE TO
EVERYBODY.
YOU KNOW, I HOPE EVERYONE'S
DOING WELL.
AS -- OH, YEAH, SORRY.
WE HAVE TO TALK ABOUT THE GAME.
AS WELL AS POSSIBLE WITH THE
GIVEN CIRCUMSTANCES.
BUT JUST WANT TO SEND MY LOVE TO
THE CITY.
THANK YOU FOR THE SUPPORT ON THE
ALBUM.
YOU KNOW I LOVE YOU GUYS SO
MUCH, MAN.
I CAN'T WAIT TO SEE YOU AGAIN
DO.
A CONCERT IN THIS BUILDING.
HAVE THE BOYS THERE, YOU KNOW.
AND YOU CAN MAKE IT A CASUAL
NIGHT THAT NIGHT, YOU KNOW.
>> Matt: WE DON'T HAVE TO
BRING A TIE?
>> NO.
YOU CAN GO LIKE NICK NURSE.
DRESS SHOES WITH THE RAPTORS'
WARMUP.
[ Laughter ]
>> Matt: OR WE'LL JUST BORROW
YOUR JACKET.
>> EXACTLY.
>> Jack: I WOULD LOOK GREAT IN
THAT JACKET.
>> Matt: THE RAPTOR HAD ONE.
>> I DEBATED ABOUT THIS JACKET
WAY TOO LONG.
NOW I REGRETTED.
I SHOULD HAVE GONE WITH
SOMETHING WAY MORE SUBTLE.
>> Matt: YOU CAN GET AWAY WITH
IT.
>> THIS ISN'T A PRE-SEASON LOOK.
[ Laughter ]
>> Matt: THAT'S A GAME SEVEN.
>> YES.
I SAW MYSELF ON CAMERAENED A
REALIZED, YEAH, IT WAS
DEFINITELY ROUND TWO -- CAMERA
AND -- SECOND ROUND LOOK.
BUT IT IS WHAT IT IS.
>> Jack: HOW ABOUT WAINWRIGHT
MAKING BACK-TO-BACK THREES,
MATTY D.
>> BECAUSE HE KNOWS WE'RE ON THE
AIR.
>> Jack: HE KNOWS YOU'RE
CALLING HIS GAME.
>> EXUM.
>> Matt: TAKE IT AWAY.
WAINWRIGHT WAS RIGHT THERE.
DAVID JOHNSON.
ALSO, DRAKE, AS WELL, IT'S
THANKSGIVING.
>> WAINWRIGHT'S HOT.
>> Matt: OH.
>> I JINXED THAT.
FRONT ROOM.
>> Matt: IT'S ALL RIGHT.
FRONT RIM.
TIED UP.
SO ALL THE WORDS THAT YOU WERE
JUST SAYING, SO THANKFUL, TOO,
ON THIS THANKSGIVING, RIGHT?
>> YES.
EXACTLY.
>> Jack: HERE HE IS,
WAINWRIGHT KNOCKING DOWN THE
JIMMY, DRAKE.
HERE'S ONE.
>> THERE HE IS.
>> Jack: HERE'S ANOTHER ONE
RIGHT HERE.
FLYNN.
DIRK.
>> MALACHI.
>> Matt: NUMBER 22.
>> WEARING THE NIKE GTs.
>> Matt: DO YOU LIKE THEM?
>> YEAH.
GOING NEW SCHOOL ON HIM FOR
SURE.
WEARING THE NIKE GT CUTS I
BELIEVE THEY'RE CALLED.
>> Jack: YEAH.
>> GT CUTS.
>> Matt: LOOKING GOOD.
>> YEAH, LOOKING GOOD.
>> Matt: HE GOT THE GOLF THING
GOING, TOO, WITH NIKE.
>> YEAH, I DON'T REALLY KNOW --
YOU KNOW, LIKE, WHO'S REALLY
GREAT AT GOLF AT THE END OF THE
DAVE?
>> Matt: NIKO.
>> NIKO'S PRETTY GOOD.
MY UNCLE
IS REALLY GOOD.
>> Jack: I'M REALLY GOOD AT
THE 19th HOLE.
[ Laughter ]
I KICK TAIL.
TAKE NO PRISONERS.
>> I LOVE THAT.
[ Laughter ]
>> Jack: YEAH, I HEAR NIKO'S
GAME HAS IMPROVED STEADILY.
>> Matt: HE'S BEEN WORKING ON
IT.
>> HE'S DEEPLY INVESTED IN THE
GOLF THING.
A LOT OF MY FRIENDS ARE.
T-REX IS INVESTED, TOO.
IT'S GREAT, YOU KNOW.
IT'S A --
>> Jack: DO YOU HAVE A GOLF
SIMULATOR?
>> NOT YET.
NOT YET.
>> Jack: A PUTTING GREEN AT
THE HOUSE?
>> I'LL GET THAT GOING FOR YOU
FOR SURE.
>> Jack: YEAH.
I'LL COME OVER.
>> Matt: YOU DON'T NEED THE
PUTTING GREEN FOR HIM.
IT'S ALL THE OTHER STUFF.
JUST HAVE A HOLE READY.
>> Jack: EXACTLY.
>> Matt: HE'S ALL GOOD.
>> OKAY, JOSH.
OKAY, JOSH.
IT LOOKED GOOD.
[ Buzzer sounds ]
[ Cheering ]
>> Matt: DRAKE CALLED IT.
>> THAT'S MONEY!
LET'S GO.
30 BAG.
OH, IT'S A 20 BAG.
>> Jack: WE'VE HAD TWO OF
THOSE TONIGHT.